folks.
I am exhausted today.
This is the end of
week three of a borderline batshit
insane cut.
Probably averaging thousand over 1,000
calorie deficit a day.
Running average now 40 miles a week
and lifting five days a week including
deadlifts every day.
On top of that, we've been doing hard
research all week. A bunch of random
meetings as well,
So, here's what I want to do today.
I don't really want to go work on
any of the existing
fancy algorithms and changes and such.
At least not for the next couple hours.
I kind of just want to have some time to
sit here,
take a step back,
and think about
where
we are algorithmically.
Welcome.
Hey, Weston.
Let me just open a Google doc.
That's pretty much the uh the long and
the short of it.
I'm writing this off the top here. How
many prams do you think a basic
feed forward neural net
would need to be to predict the location
of the second mass?
Two seconds.
Uh you have to be sure that you actually
have like forces and stuff
like velocity and stuff if you don't
have memory to do that.
I don't know. I would start with like
our basic default network architecture
though. Won
start with the basic architecture we
have.
I suppose the expectation I have for
world models is quite high, right?
You probably just need to take a lot
more gradient steps
on the world model.
architecture as well.
All the existing methods are set up this
way.
Too deep. Weston
Two hidden layers.
Observation.
Activation hidden. Activation hidden.
Uh, activation output.
Actually the efficient zero objective is
not
like the dreamer objective, right?
Is there a reconstruction objective in
this? I don't think there is. Right.
Yeah, there's no reconstruction.
no.
At least not
dynamics is going to predict.
The thing is it predicts the next state
embedding, right?
This is a hard thing to learn.
See, this is because this is a moving
target, right?
You're predicting like your next
embedding.
America's pretty damn good as it turns
out.
If you just shut off the news and
actually live here, it's pretty good.
Uh, what are we working on today?
Some thoughts,
some thinking about RL. I think we're
going to end up doing some math.
Oh,
I'd like to understand precisely
why you need to have
like to what extent the on policy
assumptions coded in Okay.
Oh, hey, that's Will.
What are you linking me to?
So, well, the thing I'm trying to figure
out at the moment,
um,
I kind of don't think world models are
the end all beall. I'm trying to see if
there's some way we can keep the on
policy formulation,
like that objective formulation, but
incorporate old data somehow.
So basically what's happened from the
last couple weeks of research is
um you kind of can't take off Paul or
world models or anything and get like a
single algorithm in which you can spend
more compute or you can spend more data
because there's a massive compute gap
between on policy and then either offpol
or world models before something works.
Like on Paul's the only thing that
actually works at the moment
consistently
Uh, I the plan for today is to kind of
just hang out and look at some math and
to think about things.
It's been a pretty tiring three weeks
and I kind of just need some time to
step back and think about stuff on this.
So if you're interested in like how do
we actually very deeply think about
these algorithms and what to do with it
the right spot for that.
Why can't you just apply this bloody
thing to
I still don't understand why it is that
this implies
why this is an on policy derivation
like why can't I just recomputee the
probabilities under a different policy
Okay.
Does anybody like Okay, obviously yeah,
this is a simple derivation, right? This
is a pretty simple derivation, but the
thing I don't understand here,
why can't I use a policy that is
different from the one that's produced
the trajectory here?
working on the end.
Enjoy learning. Good.
Wait, is it
Is there a way to cover the previous
videos? To cover the previous video?
Yeah, they're on all the VODs are on
YouTube.
Trajecctor is now unlikely, right? But
what I'm trying to figure out is like
why does that matter?
Okay, like here consider the following
scenario, right? Let's say that you have
a bunch of trajectories that come in
from um on policy like just come in from
the current policy but then I just add
in some expert trajectories but I don't
tell you which ones
right so you have some perfect so-called
perfect trajectories
according to this on policy assumption
you shouldn't be able to use them and
according to my tests as well it seems
that this messes up the algorithm
This seems like a really bad property
for an algorithm to have.
I'm resisting the urge to start typing
crap into LLMs because they're just
going to give me like I don't know. I've
tried this specific topic and you just
get a lot of circular really like dumb
entrenched thinking.
So I mean this first line very clearly
where's tow defined
uh it's sample reuse.
So the idea is
uh if you're just getting on policy
segments,
you have very little ability to learn
from them and like you can't even keep
around your best examples for instance.
Like you can't even keep around good
segments from before.
Like lucky segments for instance, you
can't even keep them around. Once you've
used them once, you're already off
policy.
Technically,
you're immediately off policy, right, at
the second mini batch. So, you're able
to learn a very limited amount from the
data,
right? But so this is what I'm trying to
figure out fundamentally like
okay this objective it's already encoded
at the objective here right because this
is you're trying to maximize the
expected return
with a trajectory of a trajectory
sampled.
This is not what you want. you want.
How would you write this?
Okay. So this objective function
immediately
but I don't think the whole derivation
does.
So the probability of a trajectory
given that actions come from pi z pi
theta
try to use less layers then I need more
total params.
Are you using the puffer implementation,
Weston?
Like, I get the desire to do everything
custom, but the thing with RL Yeah. So,
here's the problem with RL, okay? It is
really, really brittle, and it's not
going to make any bloody sense to you if
you have a custom implementation that's
not actually tested to be stable over a
wide range of problems.
Like this is not the equivalent of like
let me go implement my own cool render
algorithm or like my own cool like
domain specific whatever. It's like RL
is actually genuinely and truly an area
where just getting the basic algorithms
to work is non-trivial. Like very
non-trivial to the point that like I
would not be confident that if I spent a
day implementing any algorithm from
scratch on your problem given a correct
version of your environment, I would not
be confident I could get it to work.
That should tell you a lot.
Okay, I think so this formula is valid
whether the actions come from beta or
not. Right? This is just saying how
likely you are to see a trajectory.
What does pi sub theta give you? Is it
giving you a probability distribution?
Okay. And I think this is still valid.
Is this gradient not still valid?
Can you hint what the problem you're in
today? Yeah. So basically Satcha I'm
trying to understand exactly where and
how
uh policy gradient algorithms depend on
the data actually being sampled from the
current set of parameters.
And the hope is that I'm going to be
able to figure out new ways of
leveraging old data uh without having to
dramatically modify the policy gradient
setting.
gradient of the log prob of the
trajectory.
this is true regardless of uh where your
data comes from, right?
This step five
because this is just like
it's it's done in log space, right? But
this is basically just saying
that um the delta of a trajectory is the
delta of each of the actions taken along
the way.
So if you want to increase the
probability of a trajectory, right, you
increase the probability of taking each
of the actions. That's like completely
trivial, isn't it?
And this is basically,
isn't this the behavioral cloning
objective? Exactly.
Does anybody have a good reference to
the math?
Like you can write behavioral droning uh
behavioral cloning as log prop, right?
actually I can get this at least if I
don't give it any other like context I
should be able to Right.
That I can probably get and I can
compare.
If anybody has an actual reference, that
would be better.
But I think that you just do this, don't
you?
over n log prob action given state.
Yeah. So this is identical, right?
So this is what I was getting at before.
So this is literally
this core piece of math here
from policy gradients
is behavioral cloning.
Drop the discount from the state
distribution.
the objective differs
in a way where data comes from IID or
marovian data.
If you have specific things that I
should look at in this, please tell me
because otherwise this is a lot of math.
Um, if there's a not a specific point,
I have a somewhat broader problem with
this at the moment.
expectation of scoring data function
weighted with trajectories
is that formula there's no reward.
Yeah. So in this formula this is not the
full derivation right this is an
intermediate step of the policy gradient
derivation
but the thing is that this portion is
exactly equal to behavioral cloning like
this is the behavioral cloning objective
right this says that if you want to make
the policy
behave in a certain way this is how you
change the action distribution to match
It is but the data does not have to be
marovian.
Okay, that is true.
But like
this objective here, right?
The thing that bothers me is this
objective is literally
behavioral cloning objective
weighted by return. That's literally all
it is, right?
That's policy gradient.
Behavioral cloning does not require
anything. It doesn't even it doesn't
require the data come from the same
policy either. But somehow waiting that
data by the return now suddenly it's
required to be on policy
and I don't understand that
like yes right I understand that this
objective here this is written as
trajectories sampled from the current
policy right so this objective at the
top this encodes uh that the data has to
come from the policy pi but this portion
doesn't this is just behavioral cloning
and then the final result is behavioral
cloning rate weighted by return
you see what I
Now I suppose that there is
there is like one major confounding
factor here, right?
This is not actually the algorithm that
works in RL.
teacher policy is very different. Uh no
dam it doesn't because you don't need to
have a teacher policy. You just have to
have a data set. Behavioral cloning you
can work on any distribution.
It's that way because you need to
maximize the cumulative return which
implies you need to weight it with the
likelihoods.
You're doing the reasoning in the wrong
direction.
Um, well, you can't you do it in either
direction though? That's my point,
right?
Cuz you can set this return. You can set
this objective to one and then you have
behavioral cloning. Agree?
Like you literally you set this to one
and you just get behavioral cloning. And
behavioral cloning is very effective.
I there's one major major conflating
factor here though, right? Which is
uh vanilla policy gradients doesn't
actually work, right?
This is the And I I hate that this is
true because this is such a mess.
Why is this doing this?
Stop. Get what? What is this new stupid
Chrome feature? Go away.
what problem do you solve? You solve
behavioral cloning. Satcha. So if you
have an existing set of good actions in
state then you get a policy that
actually does that.
I got 19.5 on pong after making much
luck. Yeah. I'm doing something a little
different, Spencer, at the moment
because
the thing I don't know, I think the
world model direction is still
potentially good. And the reason it's
good is it takes very good advantage of
the hardware, but it's not going to give
us like a smooth I could be wrong, but I
don't know if it's going to give us like
a smooth transition between low data and
high data. I think it's like more of a
you have to invest a ton of compute to
match results and then you invest even
more compute and do better
maximize return which defines the okay
but like here's the thing if I just do
vanilla RL if I just do RL and uh
instead of sampling the data from the
expert like instead of sampling the data
from the current policy I just give you
data from an expert, it breaks, right?
the waiting the data by return
it actually breaks it means that even if
you have uh if you have ideal data you
can't learn from it
the world model part of your policy loss
was zero because it was no longer
tracking pre vlog
previous log props. Uh so the reason for
that Spencer is uh the previous log
props are the log props at the time that
you're collecting the data right but
because you're hallucinating new data
it's perfectly on policy like there's no
gap. The only thing that you could do is
if you wanted to track a loss like that,
you could track after the update and
before the update, but then you'd have
to do an additional forward pass to even
do that.
But like they're basically it should
just be zero
the previous log like it should be zero
because it's fully on policy, right?
Unless you're doing an extra eval
afterwards.
gradients from imitational learning to
be much larger than LRL.
But you're going to tune um
know why they would be you're going to
tune your algorithm regardless, right?
like you're going to just tune hypers to
the problem regardless.
It depends on your the scale of your
returns actually is what it is.
Mixture of what mixture of Gaussians,
man?
What mixture of Gaussians?
Dreamer has um
Dreamer has this oh that's the old form
right the one in uh dreamer is and this
is in the dreamer branch implemented
it's 32
you come up with like a 32 latent factor
and then you sample 32 different
categoricals from it it's weird
I think the idea of all these things is
that you end up with a stochastic
representation
um you're free to play with it I I'd be
shocked If that's like, yeah, if you
just do that, then you optimize the
world model so much faster that you
don't end up with problems.
The world model direction is
is useful though in the sense that um
like if you think of if we're doing
stuff on the higherend chips, right,
it's like a purely ondevice
online RL
stochastic part. Okay. But like the end
is not even stochastic, Spencer, right?
Like the the imagined rollouts are still
stochastic because you're sampling from
the policy and the policy is stochastic.
It's just the transition dynamics that
are not stochastic and we're testing it
on simple ass environments that are not
stochastic.
Spawning per pong round. Okay. So, the
other thing that I didn't handle here uh
is you're technically you're supposed to
cut the trajectories when uh the world
model predicts the done signal.
Yeah, you're supposed to cut the
trajectories off.
Okay. But this is not my objective
either. Sacha my objective here right is
in one algorithm
you should be able to learn uh from
either expert data or
uh like online data
you should be able to learn from mixed
quality data
if you have an offline RL objective that
you think is good then go ahead and show
it to me but if it has like a very short
form bootstrap or if it as important
sampling. It's probably crap.
Like as far as I've need I've seen, you
need the long form bootstrap.
It usually has a lot of that.
What? Short form bootstrap or important
sampling. Yeah. So that just screws you.
That just basically means your algorithm
sucks.
Advantage rated. Yeah. So there's
advantage weighted regression.
Um
I messed with some stuff like that a
little bit.
I could probably take another look. The
problem is the experiments there. Like
they don't have experiments from that
that are actually useful.
Um it's all this control crap.
you use data until you get smaller.
Yeah. So, I was trying to do that,
Spencer, but it does seem to be the case
that the current form of policy gradient
like it really wants your data to be on
policy.
You can't just keep reusing data until
the advantage gets smaller because it
gets to be very off policy.
I tried that.
Uh, okay. Actually, this was something I
saw yesterday. It's for freaking LLMs.
So, this is just I think I looked this
up yesterday. So this is basically just
like smoothed important sampling, right?
Yeah, this is just smoothed important
sampling.
Well, you can't forget about LLMs
because it basically means you may as
well just assume this has no usable
experiments.
Yeah, but like both okay, just having a
big KL div and doing in sport and
sampling are both just saying let's not
actually use the training data.
Right? You can't just give me an
objective that's like [ __ ] compared to
the on policy objective and be like,
"Ah, good. Now we can do off policy."
Right? It's like, no. If the objective
is [ __ ] by comparison, that doesn't
help.
We need an objective with a reason to
think that it's actually as good as the
on policy objective, right?
See, like this is useless. Okay? Why is
this useless? because this basically
just says, "Hey, if the trajectory is
unlikely under the current policy, throw
it away."
So basically, you've just written a
piece of fancy math that does the exact
same thing as just not using your data.
So that's useless, right?
Like the only thing that's salvageable
about this is that if you're keeping
around say some really good trajectories
uh that have low probability then
eventually if the policy gets good then
you can use them but like this is not
helping you actually get there. This is
a bad algorithm
lower bound of samples required to solve
an N.
Uh, I guess Spencer, like you can do
that, but the problem is you're going to
end up just going and collecting like
cherrypicked b uh baselines from a ton
of different papers if you do that with
like no respect to compute.
The thing that's actually the thing that
I actually want to have is I want to
have a reasonable compute data tradeoff
curve.
See what Satches linked to me.
Offline RL for online
online algorithms off pulsing
torches printed bringing mu on that
would be nice.
Is it possible to do transfer learning
with some hardcoded player script? Yes.
Yeah, you can do that Tim, but that's
not exactly what we're trying to do. Not
policy gradient, I forgot. What online
algorithm do they have that's not policy
gradient based?
This is also weird in that it's like
targeting exploration stuff which is
probably like one of the lowest quality
uh lit areas in RL and that's saying
something
as Q-based I see.
Yeah, we're not dealing with That
If they have um
the original J paper do
to compute or data. So Spencer, the cool
thing about that is if we do it right,
we literally shouldn't have to because
you just optimize for wall clock time
and then the simulator is running at
whatever speed the simulator runs
and then it'll it'll just use more
compute if it needs to. And you can do
that right now with Puffer. But the
thing is like
to be fair, I haven't tested, but
there's no reason to expect Puffer as it
is now to be able to scale well with
compute like at all. It really just
scales well with data.
Here's a restroom real quick. I'll be
right back, guys.
Wait, what
overall takeaway for important samplers
is to make sure in policy won't differ
much between time steps. That's not
quite true cuz important sampling
it will if a piece of data has low
probability under the current policy
it'll wait it is zero.
So it's like
it will literally just weight it as
zero.
Multilevel.
Multilevel Monte Carlo. Well,
Um,
so Satcha, the only thing I can see this
mapping on to in RL is search, right?
Like this maps onto search basically.
You don't have like iterative refinement
otherwise.
What's the typical bottleneck on RL more
focused on hardware?
Well, with it depends in what approach,
right?
With our current stuff in our current
sims, it's pretty balanced.
If you get a slow simulator, then you're
going to be bottlenecked by the
simulator.
And if you have a really fast simulator,
then you're bottlenecked by the policy.
weird to me when people go like, "Oh
yeah, it's going to be high variance
because it's a Monte Carlo estimate."
It's like literally that just means you
have a bunch of samples and you average
them, right?
Can I link a paper? Yeah, you can link a
paper.
How do you spec a system for RL?
At the moment, we have two different
machines. Uh we've got like high-end
desktops which generally have a very
nice core to GPU ratio. like you've got
a good number of cores for to uh
saturate the GPU and then we've got tiny
boxes which are 32 core six GPU machines
and uh those only are useful for the
faster environments because otherwise
you can't keep up on the data
generation.
All right, let's see what you've got
here with the map
multilevel
for average reward. Okay. I mean, if
this actually like this would be cool if
it works.
I'm trying to see how the hell you say
that you can correct an optimizer for
RL.
Can you explain to me how that this is
supposed to be?
Satcha, can you please explain to me how
this is supposed to be low variance? So,
the problem with average reward
anything, right, is that you're
predicting average reward on next step.
And while I would absolutely love it if
I did not have to roll out trajectory
segments for like 64 steps to make
estimates,
um the reality is that rolling forward
that number of steps actually lets you
see what happens in the environment,
right? If you actually follow the
policy, you don't have to estimate what
happens in the future. You just know
what happens in the future, right?
Skip connections.
Uh, skip connections are good, Weston,
but you should not be doing you should
not have deep enough architectures that
that should matter.
No, I mean this is good. Can you do you
have any explanation as to like cuz I
don't Okay, you have like average reward
is a unbiased objective, right? But I
don't see how the heck you can predict
that without the variance reduction of
actually rolling forward.
Like the key thing, right, is that
pretty much generalized advantage
estimation is the actual workhorse that
makes on policy RL work.
Did you get like a really good estimate
out of it?
See if I can understand what the heck
you've done mathematically here.
The algorithm actually rolls forward.
Okay,
then how is it average reward?
Oh, I guess you can still roll forward.
Okay. Yeah, you can still roll forward,
I guess.
Yeah, you can still roll forward, but
you just have the um you don't get the
same variance reduction, right?
Doesn't use samples to update
update the policy to correct the
gradient.
Correct the gradient.
I have no idea what this does looking at
it.
Five.
Okay. What does this do?
G is
where is G even defined? Okay. G is
equal to
2 the J
Yeah. I have I've got no idea what this
is doing. Satcha.
This stupid thing here is the only
reason RL works.
Uh we end up doing 16 core. It depends
on your environments. The thing is the
thread rippers are super expensive. So
we do like 9950x
estimation of the objective over the
batch rolled out into the future and you
did this.
Okay. So you put this advantage into the
optimizer
in AI and robotics.
They don't have degrees in AI and
robotics that don't like aren't based in
computer science. Well, maybe robotics
you can have like a different
engineering basis. There's no like
there's no like degree in AI that isn't
computer science core.
I know. It's like I can't even evaluate
this, man. This is more math than I
know.
If you think that this is like if you
think that this works, though, I mean,
you just have to do the you'd have to
push the experiments, right? Like the
cool thing with puffer is everything is
so fast that if you just write if you
write your optimizer you can very easily
do a lot of experiments on this. What
would you go with? I mean just core CS,
right?
So I guess the problem the problem with
computer science is like it's kind of
half a degree because it actually
doesn't teach you how to be a decent
programmer.
And like you really can't do much in CS
if you're not a decent programmer.
I mean I have all of my advices on uh X.
If you just check my X page on the
articles tab, I have several guides for
new people.
Method computes epstimations
of the objective over
the randomized batch rolled out into the
future. randomized
over the randomized batch.
Rolled out into the objective
estimate of the objective over the
randomized batch
out.
Isn't this what you do with uh
Isn't this what you do with just like
any of these methods? Satcha just not in
the optimizer like you do this with
advantage estimation right into an IIT
I don't know
why you'd ask an American
I don't know why you'd ask an American gay is a random variable from okay let
gay is a random variable from okay let
me see if I can actually
due to the negative JB B inverse. This
is the index.
What is the special thing about putting
the
advantage calc into the optimizer?
but for the gradient of the policy.
Monte Carlo estimates
not for advantage but for the gradient
of the policy.
Wait, but Monte Carlo estimate as it
mean as it's meant in RL literally just
means averaging over different
trajectory segments, right?
Monte Carlo estimate is used
or are you talking about rolling forward
in a single segment?
Proven AI as a finance student. I have
my guides on X if you want all of my
advice in one spot.
the as a finance student part is not
necessarily
super relevant.
Either way, you need strong CS, strong
programming background, at least a
little bit of math. As you can see, I
don't have a ton of it.
What the heck does you mean by what do
you mean Monte Carlo estimate over
a single segment? You mean that somehow
you're reducing the gradient?
You're somehow reducing the variance of
the gradient by looking forward over the
data from the same segment.
Like how?
Wait, that's what advantage does, isn't
it?
Isn't that what advantage does though?
Isn't it like this is also what
advantage does? Unless this is somehow
getting distributed differently over the
weights
or something.
I I haven't looked at Adam in a while.
Is this is this G estimate?
This G and this N.
Um these are the main differences.
I don't understand this like this whole
framing stability hinges upon a
hypothesis that the data generating
process mixes exponentially fast
with a rate parameter that appears in
step size selection.
What in the hell is that?
Hey, how's it going?
The hell does this even mean? Mixing
time
close to its steady state distribution.
What steady state distribution?
There freaking isn't one.
These are not like steady state
processes.
What are you doing? Being confused by
math.
Stationary. There isn't one though,
right?
a stationary distribution. Do you mean
steady state? Because there isn't one
but Satcha, there isn't a freaking
steady state distribution, right? This
is not like this is not like a pendulum
or a process that you're monitoring for
when it converges, right? It's an
environment. It's an interactive process
that changes throughout the entire
course of the simulation, finishes, and
then gets reset.
Or even if it doesn't reset, there's
still not a steady state. It's
constantly evolving,
Like this is why I get so confused with
these works because it's like you've
gotten so far away from the problem that
you're studying that you're just
thinking about MDPs and stuff. It's like
it doesn't even remotely this doesn't
remotely match the actual problem of
learning in an interactive environment,
right?
Like
many existing RL methods employ
stochcastic gradient iteration whose
stability hinges upon a hypothesis that
the data generating process mixes
exponentially fast.
How the hell does it hinge on that?
I supposed to understand any one of the
big worlds? No. And I don't necessarily
know if authors do either
because this basically at least as far
as I can tell and I can be wrong in this
area, right? But like
this I want to understand more. This
sort of language here I don't see how
this is applicable to the process.
Right? This is like so deep in the
formalism.
Like this is not the thing that I'm
concerned with here. Right? The thing
I'm concerned with is something that's
substantially more grounded, which is
that
this derivation of vanilla policy
gradients is literally return weighted
behed
behavioral cloning. This is behavioral
cloning. This is the discounted sum of
rewards.
So this is this formula. This is the
core of policy gradient. This waiting
prevents you from leveraging
uh past data
is one way of interpreting this.
And then additionally you actually need
advantage estimation.
You need generalized advantage
estimation for RL to even work.
Am
I interrupting something? Not
particularly. What I'm trying to do
today is I'm trying to piece through a
bunch of like a bunch of stuffy
formalism
around RL because the simpler doc is
here. Um what I found over the last few
weeks so on policy which is what we do
in puffer liib is the only thing that's
just works it works really well it works
really fast you need to have a lot of
data though and it doesn't scale great
with compute it scales really well with
data more than anything and off policy
it seems like the algorithms are
fundamentally worse than on policy it
seems that they're like fundamentally
worse because they don't do they do
credit assignment over very short
horizons basically and then they rely on
you just running a ton a ton of compute
on them to make it as good as on policy
and then you can keep running it and do
better.
World models do basically the same
thing. The results are better here but
more complex.
X cut all of my messages.
Right.
But viewing this as behavioral cloning
isn't even super helpful, right?
[ __ ] figuring out whatever that is.
Well, what I'm trying to figure out is
I'm trying to figure out the simple
version, right? Is I'm trying to figure
out how to make reinforcement learning
scale either with compute or with data
more smoothly. Instead of what we have
now, which is Puffer is really good with
a ton of data. There are other methods
that work with a ton of compute and
there's nothing in between.
Hello, welcome.
I mean this is this is the core right
here, right?
But saying this is the core is almost
ridiculous, isn't it?
This is literally just a formula that
lets you This is literally just like
moving probabilities up and down.
Well, it's moving log probabilities up
and down.
Same thing.
Leveraging offline data. You need to
make the policy aware of the expert
policy
applies important sampling or necessity
to correct gradient steps
of the up or necessity to correct
gradient steps of the update. Yeah,
basically I'm saying are we sure that
but my question Satcha is are we sure?
Are we sure that's the only thing we can
do?
book is it?
This is this is not a book. This is
advantage weighted regression paper.
If you won't regulate the policy update,
the process diverges. That's what
motivated trust region methods. But
that's not the way that I want to
address that. Satcha because trust
region methods all of them it just says
don't move the policy too much that's
not what we want right don't move the
policy too much just means don't
effectively leverage your data
I looked at this thing before I forget
what I what problem I had with Yes.
What are you teaching, sir? This is not
teaching. This is research. This is live
uh research on reinforcement learning.
I'm a scientist and engineer. I stream
all of my work on advancing
reinforcement learning.
Um, I don't understand how this paper is
good because
Can you explain to me how this is
supposed to be good
when this is billions of steps for
breakout?
This is
8 billion steps for breakout.
I actually don't understand this
algorithm.
Like apparently this is Google's better
PO or whatever, but like I don't
understand that in the context of this
resultization
want to learn CFD. Could you suggest
[Music]
reinforcement for material? Oh, okay.
You probably saw my stuff from
reinforcement learning on material
science. Uh, that's a bit different. I'm
not a material scientist, right? I'm a
reinforcement learning researcher. You'd
have to ask. There are a couple material
science people around in the puffer
discord. I have materials on
reinforcement learning. I don't have uh
materials on specific application areas.
Poses the same problem as I do. Well,
then it sucks, doesn't it? Because look,
like you shouldn't need this amount of
compute or this number of frames for
this problem.
Did you share the Twitter post you made
for new folks? The article. Yeah,
let me grab the article. I guess there
are two of them, right? There's the
programming and ML1.
There's the uh the programming and ML
one.
And then there's the RL1. So I'll link
this one.
It should work on continuous control
mostly. How the hell are there
completely different algorithms for
continuous control and for um discrete
and multi-discreet actions?
That just means we've messed up
massively.
Hey, Jess.
If I knew, then I'd solve it. Well, what
do you think I'm here doing? Right.
Uh Jess, today I'm I'm kind of going
back to basics, trying to figure out
some fundamentals on the math.
You beat odds of roulette using RL. Uh,
it's a pure game of chance. I don't know
how you would.
No. Right. It's It's a pure game of
chance
unless there's like a defect with it.
But yeah. No, it's the whole point of
that is that you can't
Oh no, it's fundamentally not a solvable
problem.
You try to optimize the distribution
given the fact that the rewards optimal
and dual problem to the original one.
Okay, cool. So why does their uh why do
the results suck on the benchmark that
Google is known for pursuing the most
aggressively?
Like I'm not going to go like spend two
days reading a giant block of math if
they don't have results. Like they don't
even have results on their the benchmark
that they themselves are using the most
of the time for everything.
Like I honestly
the control results in my mind are less
useful.
Too many benchmarks. They're too slow.
They're not competitive.
I guess the Majoko ones kind of are, but
like I'd rather see the game ones.
Continuous optimizers.
Why should you have a different
algorithm for continuous actions? That's
insane.
These are like not fundamentally
different things.
What's your education? Where from where
did you do? Uh bachelor's in CS at
Stanford, PhD at MIT. Finished that a
year and a half ago. Now I work on this.
Oh yeah. Technically you get a master's.
I technically masters as well during
PhD.
We design for continuous but it would
work with discrete. Well then why didn't
they tune it for that? There shouldn't
be a design for continuous thing.
Like I honestly, which of these two
seems more likely to you, right? That
like the algorithms need to be
completely different for continuous or
discreet or that a bunch of researchers
over optimize the crap out of a
algorithm for one specific set of
problems and that everything is super
brittle so we actually don't know what's
even good anymore. I can tell you which
one of those two is more likely based on
my time in this field.
Thank you, Janal.
Yes, you're right.
Yeah, that's the problem, right? But
that's not what I'm interested in,
right? I'm not interested in like let's
overoptimize the crap out of an
algorithm and publish a paper. I'm
interested in how do we make this field
actually work and not just be a
disgusting mess.
They're really good. Yeah. But like
I we're not going to like go say, "Oh,
you have a paper. I'm going to go spend
the next however long implementing it."
So maybe it can be good, right?
Mechanical engineering. Yeah, mech
engineering is cool.
Any of like the real like the real
engineering disciplines are good.
Is this just in the paper somewhere?
because I can't find it in the Good.
Amber Stokes using RL
uh their applications but not precisely
that way.
Just can solve some of these problems.
RL can it will change. Yeah, it's it's a
really major thing.
paper solves the same problem as VMPO
but with offline data. Is that MO that
you're trying to link?
And do they have
indices
Oh, this is massively
see this is like literally in the last
little bit of the paper you get the
[ __ ] Do you see?
So this is advantage weight regression
Jess. So this is the thing about all
these freaking papers is literally look
at this. I have to go to
the second to last page of this paper to
this like little thing at the bottom to
see at each iteration the agent collects
a batch of approximately 2,000 samples.
Okay. Updates to the value function and
policy are performed by uniformly
sampling many batches of 256 samples
from D. Value function is updated with
200 gradient steps. So that is uh that
is 40
wait hang on 250
yeah 40
uh 40,000 samples
and then the polic is updated with a
thousand gradient steps. So this is like
a hundfold sample reuse.
They're doing hundfold sample reuse.
And then they're like, "Oh, yeah, but we
beat PO.
Keep mine tries to solve your Oh, that's
cool. I didn't know that.
Do you see though how it's like how
[ __ ] it is?
This is the whole state of the field. At
least this one I know what to look for.
So this thing is just like poor.
Like this is not the problem at all.
Like that's actually something you just
solve with the optimizer.
I think we grabbed HL Gaus from this and
like tried to get HL Gaus
and actually it didn't even do much on
Puffer.
Maybe it will. Spencer's still looking
at that.
What are your criteria for a good paper?
Actually [ __ ] works.
There are flags I look for for like
things that are hidden,
misleading comparisons,
you know, things buried in appendices,
Like
the thing is a lot of these papers you
don't know until you've done a lot of
follow-up work. Like this is a good
paper, right?
Like Schulman's papers are the ones that
actually work. PO actually works.
Generalized advantage estimation
actually works.
All the same stuff is that offline RL
and MO
probabilistic inference.
What the advantage?
Oh, repo.
so many people have tried it. What repo
Hold on. Is it this one? No.
Oh, it's Peter's, not Sergey. Cool. Same
thing.
Formulate RL as the inference.
Okay, actually this does have at least
good coverage. Let me look.
Okay. So, long bootstrap is mandatory as
far as I'm aware.
15 to 17. Hang on, let me get there or
it's not going to mean anything, right?
Oh, are they just are they calling
multi-step TD L? Yeah. So, this is like
J J fits this right
closely related to J. Yes. Exactly.
Efficient one pass algorithm is reduced.
Yes. Okay.
Oh, okay. because they're going to take
a gradient of this
instead of using Okay, fine.
Includes advantage estimation is good.
This doesn't solve the um I mean this
looks like it's possibly
like this is possibly an onpaul
improvement, right? But this doesn't
solve
this doesn't solve off Paul at all,
right?
Like this does not solve off policy at
all.
To be fair, I don't really necessarily
know.
I guess I haven't actually tried with
like reinforce. The problem is like the
base methods are so bad. Like what
happens if you just do reinforce with
off policy data? like just totally off
policy data.
Does it not work?
the thing is that
Leaven says it won't work
where and does he have experiments?
So, here's the other thing that I'm
realizing is a conflating variable here,
right?
The key thing that makes on policy
actually work not just like a bit but to
work really well is generalized
advantage estimation. And pretty much
any form of any form of this is going to
have a value function trained, right?
And the thing is
if you're training a value function,
you can't train a value function on past
data, right?
the value functions also linked to the
current policy.
And that one is like not like uh
questionable from the form that one just
straight up is right. Like if you train
the value function on the wrong data,
you're not estimating the value under
the current policy. You're estimating
the value of like something stale.
Maybe that's what we should do, right?
Maybe we should um
and without the value function in the
mix.
So, basically we can separate out
uh generalized advantage estimation and
such.
we can just end up with um
discounted rewards or whatever.
Well, at least we would be able to see
if under this weaker setting,
we're able to enable like we enable data
reuse, right?
That would shift that would shift the
burden from making policy gradients work
to just making advantage estimation
work, right?
Making advantage estimation work could
be substantially easier.
Yeah, actually
I think that we have
I could
if I can make the vanilla policy
gradient formulation work.
I'm pretty confident I can modify
advantage estimation.
So, I guess that's the big question,
right?
It seems like the on policy assumption
just seems so wrong and weird to me,
right?
Because like yeah, you write out the
objective in a way that obviously
depends on the current policy,
but then the final result is literally
it's the behavioral cloning objective
weighted by return,
right?
All right, let me use a restroom real
quick. It's only three. This shouldn't
take me very long to do.
Grock, is this true? Don't ask Grock.
Grock just encodes the biases and
stupidity of everyone anyways. Like,
it's way better to just try this stuff.
Grock will just write you pages and
pages and pages and pages of garbage.
I'll be right back.
No, DQN is um DQN is like an awful
algorithm. You might see variations of
DQN. If you actually see like original
DQN in production, it's cuz people are
trolling.
All right. So this was the version that
I made.
I got to reboot the container real
quick.
your on policy
training.
Now we need to do
So this still works. We need to now make
heck of a lot of changes here.
Newest off policies. See? No, it's just
one of the more used ones.
How's your search went? Yeah, most of
the algorithms are just really stupidly
slow is the problem. Like the graphs on
paper never actually show you the wall
clock time. It seems to me like a lot of
the off-paul algorithms are just way
worse than the onpaul algorithms. And um
like to get the same amount of
performance, you need way more compute
regardless of what you do. And they get
better with more compute than onpaul,
which is the main appeal. But like it's
not like they're just better overall,
right? There's this huge gap in compute
required to get them to work.
And they don't scale well with data a
lot of the time either. They scale a lot
better with um the compute.
technical reason. My best guess at the
moment is because they use a very short
bootstrap like a three or a fivestep
bootstrap where typically in onpaul
we're using a 32 or 64step bootstrap and
the reason for that is because the
bootstrap kind of assumes on policy.
So in offall, you can't really bootstrap
over that sort of horizon without
important sampling. And important
sampling just prevents you from using
your data.
So it's a
pretty detailed
you know algorithmic
limitation.
any paper for research.
Well, that's the thing is like I the
evidence is so poorly controlled in a
lot of these that it's not like, oh
yeah, they're new ones, they're just
better. It's like they're new ones that
are better on paper and to be determined
if they actually freaking work. Uh, I
guess Beyond the Rainbow is like one of
these niche papers I saw that's like a
rain rainbow with even more stuff bolted
onto it. Um, that looked decent enough
and like it looks like relatively well
done, but the method just gets very
complicated at some point.
I
kind of fundamentally don't know if I
like offpaul without solving that
bootstrapping problem.
Like the methods are really messy as
well. Like onpaul methods are actually
pretty clean.
Like you can do a lot of damage with a
pretty simple algorithm in on Paul.
And like you're also just better in a
lot of ways that you can't match outside
of
All right. This is going to be a
problem, isn't it?
without having the value function at the
end. How the hell do you do this?
Think working on control the RL is
rational in robotics. Absolutely.
I mean, it depends, right? How much do
you like robots?
probably been gone for a week.
Uh, I got some world model stuff working
and I think that that if you're going to
spend a lot of compute, it's a sensible
approach. I don't know if it's going to
be the thing. Well, I don't think it's
going to be the thing that gets you like
smooth scaling from high compute to low
compute.
Robotics fields more sample efficient
safer with control theory. That's more
questionable,
I would say.
I have to not mess with this calc.
Before PO was our gold standard,
there really kind of wasn't one. And PO
was the first like good stable thing, I
guess, like A2C or something.
It was basically PO without clipping and
advantage estimation which is just
distributed reinforce which is not good.
It's kind of like saying like oh well
what like
PO is really the first gold standard and
it's stood the test of time.
It's like actually quite difficult to
improve it.
I mean we've made some small
improvements to it but
it's a pretty good baseline.
This is a fine basic discounted return,
right?
No, I'm doing some other stuff now This
is
This is the problem is it's actually
it's quite difficult to even
without a value function.
It's quite tough.
Oh, yeah. And you're not even going to
train.
I don't know. RL has like more pressing
issues, I think.
That actually kind of works. That's
funny.
I kind of forgot about this problem,
right?
Okay. But I mean, there's still stuff we
can do about this, right?
I think there's still stuff we can do
here.
Okay, maybe what we do,
we leave this thing
That's the same thing as just not doing
any of this.
Oh, and then this is actually kind of
too big.
the problem here is that this policy is
not good enough for us to actually play
with in any meaningful way. Right?
Just the depth.
Just be the depth, right?
I doubt it.
Probably just that it doesn't have frame
stack or anything like that, right?
Yeah, we're really like optimized to
having this memory unit,
but this memory unit causes other
problems.
Some sort of simple model I could throw
at this.
Not really right.
I guess we have to stick with this
stupid thing, huh?
I wonder to what extent you can just
like
retune
Hello, welcome.
Oh, you can just retune.
Okay. So, maybe it's worth just having
like a tuned
run with this
I just basically I need some sort of
reasonable starting point for this.
Okay. So, no, it doesn't.
It's about the best you can do.
You can ask a long question. Sure. I'll
answer what I can.
Okay.
So, this should hopefully be
this should hopefully be enough.
I actually did that at one point at
OpenAI.
You can kind of just like write down the
transition matrix for simple enough
environments as a sanity test when your
algorithms suck.
There we go.
Let's see if this does anything.
You just run a quick sweep. See if it
discovers a decent enough policy to be
usable.
Right.
So the idea of this is if I at least can
get a reasonable enough policy,
I should be able to separate the
value function learning from the policy
learning and I should be able to test
uh replay buffers, right?
Yeah, that makes sense. Now, the
question is whether this learns anything
or not. And if it doesn't, then I'm
going to need to do uh I'm probably
going to need to do some more work to
make that representation like usable.
That's going to take a while to run
though. Let me see if this process makes
sense in the meantime. Right. So the
idea I have here,
the reason we have to take the LSTM out
is because
uh the LSTM state gets messed up on
every update. So that's just one source
of error to remove
or like one source of possible
um additional like error to remove.
We separate the value and policy
function. So the representations are
disentangled.
And then what we can try to do
is we can try to learn
we can try to apply a replay buffer to
the policy learning
while keeping the value function
learning
uh we while keeping the value function
learning to be
on policy.
wait when I say to keep the value
function learning on policy does that
make sense?
Yeah, the value function has to learn
from segments that came from the current
policy.
Oops. Here's just kidding bigger
question. Let me look at this.
I've been looking at RLI training
methods in general trying to get a gist
from first principles which led me to
algorithmic information theory
growth complexity which seems to be a
lot of the origins of the core concepts
of general problem solvers. How comes
razor approach seems to fall play from
local minima.
From there, it seems like the idea of
having equal training rate across models
yields itself to getting out of those
holes. But freezing
we count the memory space is trivial.
What
ball decreases dramatically? The last
thing is isn't shrinking structure. The
hashmap is actually
Yeah, I think
you're getting into a lot of formalism
that's like interesting ideas but not
actually the underpinnings of how this
stuff works.
Um,
you're not like you're just looking at
most of supervised learning these days
at the least. You're just looking at
compression. That's all you're looking
at. You don't need to go for mcgrav like
an uncomputable measure of complexity or
like think of the model hashing stuff or
anything like that. Um,
you just have a large overparameterized
network.
that is attempting to compress data
which naturally tends to find
disentangled
uh representations.
We have good evidence of that and local
minima turn out to just not exist in
high dimensions. You have saddle points
which is why you need momentum of some
sort in your optimizer. You have poor
conditioning which is why stuff like
muon is great but that's it. You don't
actually have local minima. Local minima
occur in lowdimensional spaces such as
the behavioral spaces of of a policy in
RL. But that is different from there
being a local minima in the optimization
of weights.
And we do find that models tend to
produce compressed representations.
That was like a somewhat related answer
to your question, I suppose.
What would be better for training? like
a checkpoint system or just random
otherwise FB like you just
the thing just has to move in a
direction. It's just trying to move
forward at a at as fast as possible is
the initial task.
It should have like local observations
anyways. It probably doesn't get
absolute position. I mean so you can
just like reset it. You can just
translate it back to the origin when it
gets too far away and it's not going to
know the difference, right?
Does that
it runs forward. So, what are you trying
to do next?
That was pretty quick for knocking
together a quadriped sim.
Suppose you repurposed some of the uh
the robotics or the robot arm at least
what do you mean learn to move around?
you need like terrain
then you would generate like a terrain
map, right? And have it walk over that
look into XLSTM.
Yeah.
when I originally looked at it, it had
absolutely no practical value to me. Now
it might it might have some practical
value
but like
not necessarily on the reasons stated in
the paper
and there are some considerations as
Well,
do I want to just tolerate the
want to tolerate the LSTM drift?
I guess it does need one frame of
memory, right?
Can I hack that real quick?
A shoot. You can't even do this this
way, huh?
is there any env I can do where you
don't need
triple monitor setup with stream TFT and
VS Code.
I don't know how you get anything done
on that.
I'm sorry I'm new. What is this you're
working on? Uh so currently I'm working
on some experiments to isolate the
effects of off policiness in the
algorithm.
What are some paper authors who
generally do good work that you'd
recommend?
Onpaw algorithm side would be Schulman.
um
like source creator of uh clean rl for
his blog post on it. Uh Costa
I mean I have a list of papers in my um
my article on X that I suggest
other big ones. Oh yeah, the I mean I
have more papers like papers than I have
authors, right?
take paper recommendations
outside of those
in your article. Then
I mean you can look at some of the stuff
I've been reading lately, but the thing
is the stuff I'm reading lately is not
an endorsement of it actually being
correct. It's like mostly me trying to
get I have like a million little pieces
of evidence that I'm trying to put
together into something that actually
works.
And like that's not super satisfying,
but that's the state of RL right now.
Uh I would not suggest doing that
actually.
Like even from deep mind the majority of
their research is like misleading at
best wrong at most.
Like there's no single group that does
consistently usable work at all. Myself
included.
E weird.
Oh.
Is this one going to have the problem of
like you just being able to do whatever
and get some score?
Yeah, there are some limits. I don't
know.
Mine does a bunch of good stuff in RL.
There's some there are some things about
the way that they do their research I'm
not a huge fan of.
um at the least ver like right now
though of the big labs. Yeah, they're
the doing the best RL work. I would have
put Open AI over them back in the days
of Dota, but like OpenAI just doesn't do
it anymore at all.
I mean, it's hard to understate.
I mean, it's hard to overstate like how
good Dota was.
So, this is just straight up trolling
then because I can't get
I cannot get a reasonable policy on
this,
right? I can't get a reasonable policy
on this. So,
I think
I kind of just got to tolerate
I think I kind of just got to tolerate the potential
the potential
LSTM screw-ups.
Not as much perhaps, but there will be
just as much.
with RL you could solve. Uh I mean
you're still going to need like
supervised
learning and pre-training for certain
things.
It is I think generally more powerful.
It's again it's not RL solves
everything.
guitar solves interactivity.
what's that? Can
algma.
Um, I've never heard of this. Nope. Even
telling me what the acronym does uh is
does not help. In this case,
I'm going to do this.
It was supposed to be an MLP
replacement. What?
Not going to have a replacement for
MLPS. This is not hardware efficient.
So not sharing the um
not sharing the
value representation
Okay.
Those
are wrenching things.
Oh, because you can't move the policy
too much because the value function will
get scale.
and there's no way to test this
basically.
It's hard.
the reason that you can't train, you
can't reuse samples
is not actually because of the policy.
See,
it's because of the value function.
This actually this experiment actually
this line of inquiry here is not going
to fix it.
Get rid of this
other way I can test this thing
really isn't the problem.
They will they should usually give you
parameter controlled
baselines
paper. They should tell you how large
the model is, number of steps, and a
rough wall clock.
I had an experiment for this, didn't I?
I'm going to fall.
I kind of already
kind of already did this experiment,
kind of already did this experiment. All
right.
It's funny that the best solution I have
for this is to go into even higher data
regime.
on policy just works
ridiculously well.
like even
you're going to mess up your value
function like no matter what you do,
right?
Maybe that's then what we think about.
Maybe we think about um
All right. I to be fair, I haven't
really thought about alternate ways of
training a value function. Um
give me a minute, guys. Guys, I'm going
to use a restroom real quick and take a
minute to walk around and then I got
another 40 minutes or so uh today and
we're going to think about how we can do
how we can train value functions in a
way that's more robust
with reward function. Okay, not really.
You can check my RL guide for a lot of
content on my thoughts. Uh be right
back. Give me a minute, guys.
Okay.
So,
here's the uh the question on the map,
right?
and that at least in large part the uh
off policyiness
problem
we get
and you add value. So this just goes to
discounted return.
So this is literally predict discounted
return, right?
I don't know how to think about this. Uh
I can definitely think about this
though.
So that's thinking of value function as
predicting
We can technically test that with
like just very long horizon discounting
I suppose
and then remove the value function
entirely.
actually the exponential waiting matters
a lot as Oh,
what's the paper today? Several, man.
And basically,
let me explain. Actually, let's see if
this makes sense to you.
Okay. So, derivation for vanilla policy
gradients.
You see here
that uh the formula is set up as an
expectation over samples drawn from the
current policy. So, this is the on
policy assumption, right?
But the final result
this portion here this log prop this is
literally the behavioral clothing
objective one for one and then this is
just the return.
So the derivation even though it encodes
this on policy assumption into the
derivation the actual solution that you
get is literally just behavioral cloning
weighted by returns.
That doesn't seem to me like this should
break if you give it off policy data
because you're just pushing you're just
pushing the probabilities of the actions
in proportion to the return.
Right? That doesn't seem to have any
sort of assumption baked into it as to
where the data came from. Now, what
absolutely does have an assumption baked
in is the value function because you
never just do this, right? You're always
training a value function as part of
some advantage estimate.
And the value function is explicitly the
reward that will it's predicting the
reward obtained by or the return
obtained by the current policy.
So basically the question I have here is
if we can somehow
um remove this limitation from the value
function, can we use the core the same
core policy gradient algorithm with all
policy data?
That's what I'm figuring out at the
moment.
import pretty much I think that guy I'm
pretty sure that every single importance
ratiobased metric is bad.
Aren't these group methods all like
based on multiple completions to the
same task though
moves the value head? Yeah. by doing
something incredibly like incredibly
insane having like a ton of completions
to the same thing. This would basically
like being doing a state set to like the
same starting point, right?
And then replacing the value function
which you can just have work on an
individual sample with like a group of
64. This is one of the reasons I think
that like language model RL is
moderately insane that this is the
algorithm that they have.
subject to the same task
papers weak on math.
So I I'm pretty convinced at this point
that like any method that is based on
important sampling is bad
like important sampling just says don't
use off policy data.
it doesn't actually like correct data.
It just ignores it.
So important sampling is you take a
ratio of the probability of selecting
the action under uh the new policy and
the old policy.
So basically when uh when you get a
sequence that has low probability under
the current policy,
you just don't use it.
You don't have enough scale yet. I have
more data than you do.
You may have more parameters and more
compute, but I have more data.
Well, what I'm actually trying to do is
I'm trying to find a way to to enable
sample reuse, right?
So pretty much I've spent the last two
weeks on various different methods that
promise to make you able like enable you
to reuse old samples and they all suck.
And basically the reason that all these
methods suck fundamentally is they don't
have the long uh the very long horizon
bootstrap that you get from doing
generalized advantage estimation.
I think this is the real on policy
assumption, right?
not actually policy gradients. It's the
advantage calcitive
How does that make sense in like the
type of RL I do and what does that buy
you?
I think basically what's going on right
is that because the trajectory
because the trajectory comes from
uh this given policy
then this segment here
or this segment that you're collecting
uh you're training the value function
against it and that actually does need
to come from the current
current policy Okay.
Get enough data to get your model to a
point where it can get helpful. You're
waiting to get enough data. No, I the
problem that I have at the moment is
there's no way to revisit old data at
all. Like you can get a lucky segment,
right? And there's literally no way to
revisit it.
No. So I literally I have an example
where
I just give a replay buffer
to our algorithm
and I keep in the highest advantage old
segments.
Only the high advantage ones, mind you.
And it like monotonically decreases
performance even on simple tasks
as you increase that buffer size. And
the crazy thing about it is actually on
some of the harder tasks uh if you have
just a very very small buffer
you can actually like 10x performance
early in training
because you have you solve this sparse
exploration problem with this buffer.
early data. No, because advantages are
actually on policy, right?
Advantage is a function of
uh
it's trained on the current trajectory
segment. So basically, you're assuming
that because you're training on the
segment, that's what the policy will
produce.
Yeah, I know. But basically, so what's
happened is over the last three weeks,
I have not been able to get a single
uh sample reuse method to do better than
baseline under any circumstances.
Get ready to re-evaluate advantage from
your I already do that. I already
re-evaluate advantage every single time.
I guess I haven't removed like all the
conflating variables. I suppose
I thought about the LSTM hidden estate.
Um,
I don't think that's it.
Yeah, literally you give it
it's literally about the same, even a
little worse, even with just a tiny
amount of data.
Yeah, those don't exist. These not
working ones.
Oh, actually, if you have a the fast
slow LSTM is like basically the one
hierarchical thing that actually might
kind of work.
All the other ones are sort of
bullshitty. I don't even know if the
fast slow thing works. It just might
work, you know.
Yeah. So, what you're predicting is like
let's just get rid of these.
You're predicting um
exponentially weighted average
of
endstep bootstraps.
Tested my network almost. It worked.
200.
you don't get the full estimate right
you don't get the full estimate for all
of your data.
You actually it decays pretty quick
honestly.
Like
all right, I hadn't actually thought of
that.
yeah, like breakout has this tiny
lambda. Okay.
You know, it probably you probably don't
even need like a crazy long horizon
bootstrap,
do you?
just that the trailing end of your
buffer, right,
doesn't get the full bootstrap. So, you
make it longer to average it out. Okay,
that's definitely true.
What did I miss?
Uh, mostly
I think the real culprit is the value
function.
the value function having to be really
strongly on policy.
We got this like really weird set of
rams there, didn't we?
I don't know, Weston. It's hard to say
if you're not on um like a mature well
test implementation.
You're kind of just like wandering
around in the dark is the problem with
that.
implementing yours.
You say you're implementing mine. Are
you like putting it into puffer? Like
the the best way to do stuff on this is
to do like make the minimal possible
change to puffer lib to test your idea.
Like the only stable starting point
So, it's not a crazy long bootstrap, but
it's longer than um
it's longer than what's going to get
used
Really,
this is really the source of all of our
problems.
Your end was a pendulum.
All
right. Well, that's my signal for today.
Um, I got a meeting to get ready for and
then I've got to go to dinner.
I will be back tomorrow doing research.
I'm not entirely sure what. I'm going to
have to think about this a bit and see
if I see a productive avenue for this.
I think I'm at least closing in on the
right set of problems though.
Definitely I'm understanding this in a
way that very very few people have put
the time into to understand
and backed with a lot of practical
results as well. Um, for folks who've
been watching me bang my head against
this for the last five hours,
thank you for tuning in.
If you're interested in my work,
puffer.ai for all the things,
feed the puff for a star helps me out a
lot.
Join the Discord if you want to get
involved. This is all open source work.
It's not all hard research. There's a
lot of like fun low-level gamedev that
actually helps us advance the research.
These are all playable online.
You can also follow me on X for more
reinforcement learning content. I write
about my work every so often. I have
some nice guides on there and so forth.
It's been a heck of a long week. A lot
of work, but uh I'm gonna get some rest.
I'll be back tomorrow.